Vsauce!
Baby hammerhead sharks are born in groups
of 12 to 15 and as soon as they're born they're
orphaned by their parents.
The litter huddles together and swims toward
warmer water until they are big enough to
defend themselves... from cuteness
What the FAK
The facts and knowledge on killer animal babies
White rhinos can weigh nearly 8,000 lbs and
their babies are born weighing over 100 lbs
after a 16 month pregnancy!
Each female is only able to give birth every
two to three years.
The babies nurse for up to a year even though
they can graze early on, and they stay with
their mothers for up to 3 years before venturing
out on their own.
Baby rhinos are rarely attacked because of
their mother's vigorous protection and their
tough skin.
Baby rhino fact: The moms use their horn to
protect their young.
Wolves are known for their pack mentality
and amazing hunting abilities.
They've entered folklore like Little Red Riding
hood and werewolves because of their fierceness,
but it's hard to imagine a vicious werewolf
when looking at a baby wolf.
Born in a litter of four to six pups, baby
wolves are faced with a mortality rate of
30-60% because of the numerous dangers around.
The mother wolves do their best to protect
them by birthing inside of a den or cave and
have even been seen acting as decoys to lure
bears away.
They start eating meat at 4-5 weeks old, then
begin to hunt small animals like rabbits as
preparation to become a member of the pack
and hunt larger game.
Baby wolf fact: Mama wolves massage the tummies
of the babies with their tongue to help them
pee!
Grizzly bears can easily overpower any animal
in their territory, even wolves and cougars
will give up their prey when a Grizzly approaches.
Hunters learn how to avoid bear attacks because
of the danger and the sheer size of these
animals but grizzly bears are often the most
dangerous when protecting their young.
Usually in sets of two, Grizzly cubs are born
during the late winter months during hibernation
while the mother is in a deep sleep.
Cubs will stay with their mom for 2-3 years
before venturing out on their own, and even
though the mother protects them, nearly half
don't make it past the first year due to disease,
starvation, and predators that include male
grizzlies.
Baby Bear fact: Baby grizzlies are able to
climb trees to catch prey and avoid danger,
but get too heavy to do so as adults!
Baboons warn off predators by walking in a
threatening manner while baring their large
canines and screaming, they're also fast and
strong, but when caring for their young it's
a much different story.
Female baboons only have one baby at a time
that they carry under their belly for the
fist five to six weeks, after which they will
hop up on their mother's back.
They're protected by the entire troupe and
once males reach four years old they find
their own troupe, however females stay with
the same one throughout their lives.
Baby Baboon Fact: In baboon society babies
are protected so no other baboon will threaten
anyone carrying a baby!
Hippo's have been known to be aggressive towards
each other and even rumored to overturn boats
and be dangerous to humans but, they look
like this when they're born, so yeah.
Mothers typically only give birth to one baby
at a time that weighs up to 100 pounds.
They're born underwater, where they have to
quickly reach the surface to get their first
breath of air.
Hippo moms have to stay in deep water to stay
cool and out of the sun, so baby hippos will
ride on their mom's back.
Much of the mom's time is spent to protecting
the baby from predators while it is too young
to fend for itself.
Baby Hippo Fact: Standing up is hard...
Adult lions are fast, strong, and feared.
Baby lions are adorable.
Female lions isolate themselves in a safe
place, away from the pride for up to eight
weeks, while giving birth to one to six babies.
There are all kinds of dangers the lion cubs
are faced with including hyenas, leopards,
jackals, pythons, and eagles.
But the dominant males of their own pride
can often be the most dangerous.
The cubs are very playful and the mother is
tolerant of their silly behavior because playing
helps fine tune their skills as adults by
first learning to stalk and pounce on each
other.
Baby lion fact: Baby lions can nurse from
other females in their prides, not just their
own mom!
Despite being highly venomous and feared around
the world, the female king cobra is a very
dedicated parent.
They build nests in which they lay 20-40 eggs
and they stay with the eggs until hatched,
which takes 60 to 90 days.
But once the baby cobras are born, they're
on their own.
They are able to spread their hood and strike
on the same day they're hatched.
But even though they are much cuter when they're
babies their venom is just as potent as that
of their adult counterparts.
Baby Cobra fact: There's a yolk sac in the
baby's stomach that feeds it for two weeks
until it finds food on its own.
Adult alligators are prehistoric-looking and
frightening to almost everyone, but their
babies are much less intimidating.
The babies come equipped with an "egg tooth"
that allows them to break through the shell
of their egg when it's time to hatch.
Once they're hatched the mother will defend
the nest and help them get to the water to
avoid predation of birds and raccoons, but
their biggest enemy is adult alligators.
They stay with their mothers for 2 years before
venturing out on their own, and can even be
seen riding on their backs.
Baby Alligator fact: The sex of the offspring
is determined by the temperature of the nest!
I'm going to leave you with this...
What is it and what's its nickname?
Leave your answer in the comments below and
all of the footage for this video was actually
provided by my friends over at BBC Worldwide.
They have an incredible YouTube channel called
Earth Unplugged so click here to check that
out or find the link at the top of this video's
description.
And make sure that you subscribe!
And as always - thanks for watching.